THANK YOU FOR COMING TO THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE HEARING ON JUNE
THIRTEENTH.
I WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM ALL WE HAVE ONE EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE NO AUTHORS SO
AUTHORS ARE LISTENING.
NOW'S A GREAT TIME.
BEFORE BEGINNING HAVE A
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT TO
MAKE OF A LETTER FROM THE
SPEAKER APPOINTING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE FOR
JOINING US.
AND WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE HARPER.
CALDERON. MARK STONE MARK STONE
HERE MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE WEBER.
WEBER HERE NEVER QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT.
WHEN TAKE A BREAK SINCE WE HAD
AUTHORS
SENATOR ALLEN THANK YOU FOR
BREAKING AWAY FROM THE
CELEBRATION ABOUT THE WORLD CUP.
THAT I KNOW YOU'RE EXCITED FOR.
WELL JOIN US CONCERT FEWER.
WILL BETTER INFORMED YOU KNOW
THE WORK OF SOME TOMORROW YEAH I
I'M MORE MADE THE U. S. GETTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX OH THAT'S
TRUE YEAH THAT IS A THAT
EXCITING KNOWS.
MEMBERSHIP OF A SECURE I WAS I
WAS THAT WE WERE WE WAITING FOR
OUR OWN QUORUM OF RELIGIOUS
COMMITMENT.
YOU COMMITTEES FAR MORE
DISCIPLINE THAN OURS AND I.
MUST BE BECAUSE OF THE GREAT
LEADERS OF THE CHAIRS.
WELL I'D YOU PERSON OVER IN THE
COMPLIMENTS RIGHT ALRIGHT SO LET
ME. THAT I PRESENT SP TEN
EIGHTEEN WHICH A.
HAS TO DO WITH REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION TO LT ME START BY.
EXCEPT MEAN AMENDMENT SUGGESTS
ANALYSIS AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING SO
HARD. WITH MY OFFICE IN THE
FOLKS AND COMMON CAUSE AND
OTHERS TO. TO IMPROVE THIS BILL.
SO THIS BILL BUILDS UPON PASSED
LEGISLATION BY GIVING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
THE AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH
INDEPENDENT HYBRID OR ADVISORY
COMMISSIONS.
AND IT MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
STREAMLINING CLARIFY THE LAW.
ALLOWING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
CREATE REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS.
AND BEGINNING WITH THE APPROVAL
PROPOSITION ELEVEN NOT BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THEM FOREVER
HERE.
REMEMBERS IT WELL.
THAT WHICH THAT CREATED THE
CITIZENS WERE DIFFERENT
COMMISSION THIS YEAR SEE.
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
MISSIONS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
STRICT LINES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AS YOU ALL KNOW OF
COURSE OUR STATE ASSEMBLY ARE
SENATOR BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
AND OUR CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS
ARE ALL DRAWN BY.
THE AS CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING MISSION.
NOW.
A FOLLOWING ON THAT DRIVEN BY
LOCAL NONPARTISAN.
REDISTRICTING INTEREST THAT WAS
OUT THERE I AUTHORED.
L. S. B. ELEVEN OH EIGHT
BACKING TWENTY SIXTEEN. WHICH
AUTHORIZED ALL COUNTIES AND
CITIES TO ESTABLISH AN
INDEPENDENT OR ADVISORY.
REGISTERED COMMISSION HOW
CLOSELY.
BASED ON THE THE STATEWIDE MODEL
SO THIRTEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDING CITIES OF SAN DIEGO
MODESTO OAKLAND SACRAMENTO. HAVE
ALL STEPPED UP IN ESTABLISH
THESE INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS.
MOST BASICALLY MOVES THE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS FROM THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS THEMSELVES OF
SUCH A. DEEPLY VESTED INTERESTED
NOW THAT THE LINES ARE DRAWN
OVER TO THESE INDEPENDENT.
COMMISSIONS
NOW THIS BILL BUILDS UPON THAT
PASSED EFFORT. BY NOW EXTENDING
THIS OPTION THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES
WERE NOW EXTENDING IT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE DISTRICTS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
AND WE THEN GIVE THEM THE
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH
INDEPENDENT HYBRID OR ADVISORY
COMMISSION SAYS WILL BRING. MORE
TRANSPARENT NONPARTISAN
REDISTRICTING TO LOOK AT THEIR
SECTIONS ARE THE STATE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IT'LL
PROVIDE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH
THE CHOICE.
HAVE UTILIZING INDEPENDENT
HYBRID ADVISORY REDUCING
COMMISSIONS A DOZEN MANDATE THAT
IT DOES THAT THEY DO THEY DO SO.
.
SO.
YOU KNOW WITH THAT BEING SAID I
CAN TALK TO MARK IN DETAIL BY BY
BELIEVE WITH ENJOYS. SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND.
HAVE A HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE NICHOLAS I DON'T
HEAR FROM COMMON CAUSE DOOR ROSE
AS WELL FROM LEGAL MY VOTERS.
AND THEY'RE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF BILLS WELL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR BERMAN MEMBERS
NICHOLAS I DON'T WITH COMMON
CAUSE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. COMING BECAUSE FIRMLY
SUPPORTS INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS
AS A BEST PRACTICE IN
REDISTRICTING STUDIES OF
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S COMMISSION.
FIND THAT THEY TYPICALLY DO A
BETTER JOB THAN LET'S THE BODIES
DRAWING DISTRICT BOUNDARIES LONG
A NUMBER OF METRICS INCLUDING
KEEPING COMMUNITIES CITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS INTACT. PROMOTING
PARTISAN FAIRNESS THOSE
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MINORITY REPRESENTATION.
IN CALIFORNIA IS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONS SINCE CREATION THE
STATE COMMISSION WE SEEN A SURGE
OF INTEREST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND CREATING INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS.
SAY THEY'RE FOURTEEN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH COMMISSIONS
MOSTLY CHARTER CITIES.
BUT IN RECOGNITION THIS DEMANDS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE SENDER
AUTHORED LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
PASSED S. B. ELEVEN NO WAIT
TARTARUS COUNTIES IN GENERAL LAW
CITIES TO ESTABLISH COMMISSIONS.
IF THEY WANT TO.
THIS BILL DOES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT THINGS MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT ALLOWS SELDOM
MENTIONED A COMMUNICABLE
DISTRICTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS CREATE
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS IF THEY
WISH TO.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT A NUMBER OF
INTEREST FROM SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AS WELL SPECIAL DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBERS INCLUDING THIS
COMMITTEE RECEIVING. NUMBER OF
LETTERS FROM SUCH MEMBER SAYING
THEY'D LIKE THE SAME AUTHORITY
THAT WE ARE TO EXTEND TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE THESE COMMISSIONS. WE SEE
NO REASON WHY WHICH DEPRIVE THEM
OF THE BUILDING IF THEY WANT TO
ADOPT A BEST PRACTICE.
THE BILL ALSO DOESN'T FINE
TUNING ON EXISTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS FOR
EXAMPLE BY PROHIBITING
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS FROM
ENGAGING. IN PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING.
THE BILL ALSO RELAXES SOME OF
THE COMMISSION ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS IN
RECOGNITION OF COMMON CAUSE ON
THE GROUND EXPERIENCE
PARTICULARLY WITH SMALLER
MIDSIZE COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE A
SMALLER POTENTIAL POOL OF
APPLICANTS SWEAR FLEXING SOME OF
THE OLD WILL BE REQUIREMENTS WE
CAN MAKE IT EASIER FOR SUCH
COMMUNITIES ESTABLISHED
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS.
FINALLY THE BILL DOES JUST A FEW
A FEW REWARDING IS TO MAKE THE
BILL THE EXISTING LEGISLATION OF
A CLEAR FOR EXAMPLE BY
SPECIFYING THAT. ALL OF THE BILL
REFERS TO RE DISTINCT MISSIONS.
COMMUNITIES CAN ALSO CREATE
DISTRICTING INDEPENDENT
DISTRICTING COMMISSIONS WHICH
REVIEW COMMISSION
THE STATUS OF DISTRICT LINES FOR
THE FIRST TIME AND SUPPOSED TO.
READ DRAWING THOSE LINES.
SO CONCLUDE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP AND PROMOTING THE
BEST PRACTICES IN REDUCING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN JUST A
LEADING LIGHT ON INDEPENDENT
AFFAIR REDISTRIBUTE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL TO THIS BILL WE
CAN CONTINUE. TO BE A LEADING
LIGHT ON LOW PURCHASING AS WELL
CRAWLEY'S REASON FOR VERY PROUD
SPONSORED LEGISLATION IN THE
SPORT CLEAR TONIGHT THOUGH.
THANK YOU FOR.
MORNING WOMEN IN LOS AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS CALIFORNIA THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN EIGHTEEN.
WE'VE SUPPORTED SP ELEVEN AWAY
AND THIS IS AN EXCELLENT
CLARIFICATION AN EXPANSION OF OF
THAT BILL.
THE LEAGUE.
ENDORSES REDISTRICTING PROCESS
SEASON PROCEDURES AND AND AND US
STANDARDS THAT PROMOTE FAIR AND
EFFECTIVE REPRESENTATION.
AND MAXIMIZES TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
AND THAT.
WE BELIEVE THAT REDISTRICTING
SHOULD BE DONE BY INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIPS.
THAT REPRESENT THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE OF AND THAT REALLY PROTECT
MINORITY INTERESTS.
THAT'S AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS WHOLE.
IBM STRUCTURE.
VIA WE EXPLICITLY REJECT ANY
KIND OF PROTECTION OF INCUMBENTS.
UP WE WE.
REJECT ANYTHING THAT.
.
FAVORS ONE POLITICAL PARTY OVER
ANOTHER.
ON ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE.
ARE REFLECTED IN THIS BILL THAT
THAT EXPECT.
.
THE PREVIOUS ONE. THE THE UP IT
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
CLARIFY THAT REDISTRICTING.
HE THE BED THAT THE.
BILL INCLUDES DISTRICTING
INITIAL REDISTRICTING OF FIRST
IMPRESSION INCLUDING YEAH IN
ADDITION TO REDISTRICTING.
THE CLARIFICATION THAT HYBRID.
COMMISSIONS OF GOTTA Q. TO THE
SAME STANDARDS INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS YOU TO ENTER THE
TRANSPARENCY AND INDEPENDENCE IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
EXPANSION OF FROM COUNTIES AND
CITIES TO OTHER JURISDICTIONS IS
ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIC VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS.
THAT THIS BILL. THAT WE SUPPORT.
BASICALLY WHAT THIS DOES IT'S
IT'S THE NEXT STEP IN GIVING
POWER BACK TO THE PEOPLE IT'S
THE NEXT STEP IN ENSURING THAT.
PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING THEIR OWN
REPRESENTATIVES INSTEAD OF VICE
VERSA AND THE LEAGUE SUPPORT
STRONGLY.
SP TEN EIGHTEEN IT URGES THE US
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M EMILY CHILD ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SAYING NON ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THE ANY BETWEEN
EARNERS
SEEING NONE. BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR WHOEVER MOVE THE
BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR ALLEN COMPLETE
FREE SHEET THE. GREAT TESTIMONY
IN THE SUPPORT FROM MY OUR
FRIENDS AT LEGAL VOTERS IN AND
COMMON CAUSE AND AND.
I RESPECT US RIVAL CLOTHES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
SUCCESS OF THE CITIZENS WERE
DISTURBING COMMISSION. THE STATE
LAWS CREATED A DEMAND FOR SUCH
COMMISSIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL ADDRESSES NINE SEVEN THE
RIGHT PRIMERS FOR IT AND SO I'D
STRONGLY RECOMMEND. A YES VOTE
YOU CAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THINK THAT.
I'M SECRETARY OF THESE CULTURAL.
BERMAN AYE AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING CALDERON. MARK
STONE. MARK STONE AYE MULLIN.
STEINORTH
STEINORTH AYE WEBER AYE WEBER
YE.
IF YOU EVER SO THAT'S OUT AND
LOOK THE ROLE OPEN.
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP WE HAVE SANDOR STERN.
I WITH BILLS I'LL LET YOU
SURPRISE US TOUR WITH WHICH ONE
YOU WANT TO GO PERHAPS.
YEAH.
A.
LET'S GO ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
ALRIGHT.
UNDER WITNESSES OFF THINK WE
HAVE RYAN.
GREAT.
SO WITH SO I THINK IT'S HERE'S
WELL.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
.
THE VOTING REGISTRATION PROCESS
AND VOTING ITSELF CAN.
BE CONFUSING TO MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
DESPITE ALL THIS SIMPLIFICATIONS
REMAIN THE PROCESS.
.
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
PAPERWORK THAT IS INEFFICIENT IN
OUR SYSTEM OPAL FORMS BEING
FILLED OUT AND A LOT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE TIME AND EXPENSE
BEING CONTRIBUTED TO. A THE
PROCESS OF
GATHERING REGISTRATION.
AND ACTUALLY COUNTING THOSE
BALLOTS ACCURATELY THIS BILLS
DESIGNED TO SIMPLIFY THE
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS.
BY ALLOWING US TO USE THOSE
PROVISIONAL BALLOT ENVELOPES
THAT.
BEFORE VOTER REGISTRATION
PURPOSES WELL YOU'RE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO TO SIGN AN AFFIDAVIT
ON ALL YOUR REGISTRATION.
AND AS WELL AS THAT PROVISIONAL.
BALLOT REGISTRATION.
BUT IT'S A TWO STEP PROCESS
RIGHT NOW WE FEEL LIKE IT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE AND WILL BE JUST
AS TRANSPARENT AND JUSTICE OF
FRAUD RESISTANT.
TO HAVE TWO SIGNATURES BECOME
ONE AND.
.
I'LL KEEP IT SIMPLE IN SHORT
THEY'RE IN AND LET YOU ALL ASK
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
IT BUT I'VE FOLKS WHO KNOW A LOT
MORE THAN I DO HERE WITH ME
TODAY SO.
PA ALL KEEP IT SHORT AND SWEET
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THERE THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD A YES SO SOS.
SECRETARY STATES OFFICE HERE SO
SPONSORED BY SECRETARY STATE AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS ELECTION OFFICIALS SO
RYAN OR.
YET EITHER ONE OF YOU YOU GUYS
CAN FIGHT FOR THE FOR IT THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ATTEND MOREHOUSE OR ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF STATE.
PADILLA A SECRETARY OF STATE IS
SPONSOR OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
WE THINK SENATORS STERN BROTH OR
IN THE MEASURE AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND I RYAN RONCO.
FROM THE PLASTIC COUNTY COURT
RECORDER A REGISTERED VOTERS AND
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
PARKS ELECTIONS OFFICIALS I
LEGISLATION COMMITTEE CO CHAIR.
I THINK YOU CENTER STERN FOR
RIDE THIS BILL I S. B. SEVENTY
EIGHT ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
MAKE A SMALL BUT SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATION BY STREAMLINING.
THAT THE CONDITIONAL
REGISTRATION AND VOTING PROCESS
ABOUT RAISING COUNTIES TO MERGE
THE INFORMATION OF A VOTER
REGISTRATION AFFIDAVIT AND THAT
PROVISIONAL BALLOT ENVELOPE
TOGETHER. ALL THE SAME CHECKS
AND BALANCES WILL STILL EXIST
AND LAUNCH PAD NOW. THEY SHALL
STAY IN PLACE BUT BOTH VOTERS IN
POLL WORKERS WILL HAVE A BETTER
ELECTION DEXTER%
WE BELIEVE AND WE I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
STAND READY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE'RE READY FOR MOTION OURS
AND THE SECOND OF ANYONE WANTS
TO MAKE ONE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SECOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
MUCH IN THE SECOND.
LIEBERMAN VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY CHILD ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ST ON A BRING A BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS VICE YOUR HARBOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP MISTER
CHAIR I TWO ISSUES I HAVE THIS
ONE IS THE OVERALL ISSUE THE
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION.
I'D THAT OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
THE SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION
I HAVE REQUIREMENTS OF ID OR
PROOF OF RESIDENCY OR.
OTHER THINGS FIVE WHETHER BE
ILLINOIS MINNESOTA COLORADO.
CONNECTICUT OR NEW HAMPSHIRE
AYE IN OUR SYSTEM STILL HAS A
BIG GAP IN THAT.
AND SO RATHER THAN NOW YOU KNOW
EVEN A STATE LIKE ILLINOIS
REQUIRES TWO FORMS OF
IDENTIFICATION BUT.
BUT WE HAVE THAT GAP.
GAP HERE.
SECOND ISSUE I WANTED TO BRING
UP.
BEYOND THAT AND ASK FOR YOUR
CLARIFICATION IS IN THE
PREPARATION FOR THE BILL WE
DIDN'T HAVE LIKE A MOCK.
IN TERMS OF WHAT IT DOES WHAT IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE AYE EUROPE.
ENVELOPE YOU KNOW TYPICALLY
LETTER SIZE BUT BUT I'M FAMILIAR
WITH THE VOTER REGISTRATION FORM
WHICH IS. EVEN LONGER THAN LEGAL
SIZE HOOKING KIND OF KIND OF
CLAIRE FIRE WALK THROUGH WHAT
THAT WHAT THE PROCESS BECAUSE
I'M LIKE WONDERING IS IT GONNA
BE LIKE AN ENVELOPE LIKE THIS.
PROBABLY NOT LIKE THERE IS A BET
THAT BUT HOW BUT GET OUT WE KNEW
WE HAD THE.
I THINK THESE ARE FOR
CERTIFICATE DOT ORG BUT.
BUT NEVER THE LESS HOW HOW IS
THAT ENVISIONED AYE
IMPRACTICALITY SO THAT WHEN I GO
IN REVERSE OR AND TAKE YOUR
SECOND QUESTION FIRST AND
DEFERRED THAT TO.
OUR FOLKS IN THE REGISTRAR'S
JUST TO GIVE A SENSE
THERE IF YOU DON'T MIND YEAH
SURE I. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HARPER I THINK YOU GET IT
WOULD BE A VERY LARGE AND LEFT
FOR A FOR SURE I'VE RIGHT NOW
MANY COUNTIES USE A OVERSIZED
ENVELOP NOT A LETTER ENVELOPE
BUT. AN ENVELOPE THAT IS MAYBE
THAT THE MID SIZE VERSION OF THE
INPUT THAT YOU JUST HELD UP AS
THEY AYE AS THE ENVELOPE FOR
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
OR PROVISIONAL. AT BALLOT
ENVELOPE AS WELL WHICH ARE TWO
DIFFERENT PROCESSES BUT
BASICALLY THE SAME THING. AYE
AND THE INFORMATION THAT YEAH
CAN I BE CONTAINED ON THAT%
ENVELOPE SPECIAL USING BOTH
SIDES OF THE ENVELOPE. WOULD
CERTAINLY HANDLED THE
INFORMATION THAT'S REQUIRED ON
AN AFFIDAVIT OF REGISTRATIONS.
THANK YOU THAT ADDRESS MY
QUESTION AND THEN AS TO THE
FIRST QUESTION I I THINK WE CAN
DEBATE THAT THE MERITS OF.
OF SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION
I WOULD SAY THIS BILL. IS IN
ABOUT THAT IT'S ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS OF OF
PROVISIONAL BALLOTING AND AND
AND VOTER REGISTRATION MECHANICS
BUT.
COUNTY STILL HALF TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE WHETHER THEY'RE A VOTER
CHOICE COUNTY OR.
ANOTHER COUNTY THAT'S THAT'S
DESIGNATING SPECIFIC SATELLITE
LOCATIONS TO DO THOSE SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATIONS.
THAT'S THE THAT TRIGGER IS STILL
REQUIRED IN LAW THIS DOESN'T
REMOVE THAT SO IT'S STILL AT THE
COUNTY'S DISCRETION A.
TO MAKE THAT DECISION AND I AYE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT THAT.
WE'RE SORT OF TRYING TO STAY
NARROW ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE.
I HAVE MY OWN OPINIONS ABOUT
THE THE MERITS OF SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION BUT. I I I REALLY
YET THAT'S NOT THE THE ISSUE
THIS BILL'S TRYING TO SOLVE I
WOULD JUST I WOULD OFFER THAT.
RIGHT RIGHT GOT. FROM OUR VERY
PEOPLE CHIEF CONSULTANT THAT
THESE ARE ENVELOPES AT THE POLLS
RIGHT SO IT'S NOT AS IF. THAT
LARGER.
AND LOOK TO POINT NUMBER TWO AS
IF THAT LARGER ENVELOPES GOING
OUT YOU KNOW THROUGH THE POSTAL
SERVICE YEAH RIGHT AND IT OR DO
YOU CHIMNEY SANTA DELIVERS YOU
KNOW GIANT THINK RIGHT IT'S JUST
THERE AT THE POLLS AND SO WE
THINK PROCESSING. LOOK IS KEYED
NON FISCAL BUT I THINK TO SAVE
MONEY AND AND I THINK THAT THE
THE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE AND MAY
WE CAN DEVELOP THAT NOW HOUSES
FOR THE FOURTH FLOOR BACKSEAT
THINGS THAT TAXPAYERS SABER SO.
ANYA THANK YOU PROCLAIM YET
PATIENT OF COURSE.
STEINORTH.
SO I I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
ABOUT PROVISIONAL BALLOTS IN
GENERAL JUST BECAUSE IT IS KIND
OF ONE OF THOSE AREAS WITHIN THE
ELECTIONS CODE THAT'S KIND OF
DARK. IT'S NOT A LOT OF LANGUAGE
AND PROVISIONAL BALLOTS AND SO
IT'S LEFT UP TO THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES TO DETERMINE HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PROCESS THEM
INDIVIDUALLY WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
DECISION MAKERS. ON HOW
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS ARE BEING
CAST BECAUSE OUR ELECTIONS CODE
IS SILENT MEANS I I THINK THAT'S
A GREAT PLACE TO START. MAYBE TO
START ACTUALLY PUTTING THE SAME
VOTE BY MAIL PROVISIONAL
RESTRICTIONS ON PROVISIONAL
BALLOT BECAUSE I'LL TELL YOU MY
SIXTEEN RACE THERE WERE NINE
PERCENT OF THE OVERALL ABOUT
BALLOTS CAST WERE PROVISIONAL
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT.
AND MAJORITY OF THEM WERE
FRAUDULENT
THE MAJORITY WERE THROWN OUT
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THEY SPEND
TWENTY ONE DAYS PROCESSING THEM
THEY CAN COME UP WITH A
LEGITIMATE REASON TO ACTUALLY
MAKE JUSTIFICATION. THEY WERE
LOOKING AT SIGNATURES THEY
WEREN'T LOOKING AT ADDRESSES AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE
WAS JUST A MATTER OF HOW DO WE
COUNTIES VOTE. AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE WITH SAME DAY
REGISTRATION AND THE FACT THAT
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS FRAUD
IN THE PROVISIONAL BALLOTING
SYSTEM WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD WE
WANT TO TRY AND MERGE THEM
TOGETHER BECAUSE. TRADITIONALLY
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS INTENDED FOR
TWO PURPOSES.
I GOT MY VOTE BY MAIL I FORGOT
IT I WANNA GO VOTE I'D AND BRING
IT WITH ME I GET A PROVISIONAL.
I GO INTO A POLLING PLACE
BECAUSE I'M NEAR WORK MY WORK IS
NOT WHERE I WHERE I LIVE I'M
RUNNING LATE I WANNA GO VOTE BY
SHOW WEAPON I SAY HEY. I'M NOT
ACTUALLY REGISTERED HERE I'M
REGISTERED IT A DIFFERENT
POLLING PLACE I'D LIKE TO VOTE
PROVISIONALLY.
THOSE ARE USUALLY THE TWO
REASONS THAT PEOPLE WOULD VOTE
PROVISIONALLY SO IN THE CASE
WHERE YOU HAVE SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION WHY WOULD WE NEED
THIS OVERLAPPING WHEN WE SEE
THAT IN MY EXAMPLE SPECIFICALLY.
NINE PERCENT OF THE VOTES THAT
WERE CAST
HALF OF THEM WERE THROWN OUT IS
JUST COMPLETELY FRIED.
I MEAN I I THINK IT'S A BIGGER
PUBLIC POLICY QUESTION THAT.
ISN'T IS A VALID DEBATE I I
DON'T I THINK.
YOU MAY VIEW THE SYSTEM IS IN
PERFECT OR.
FLAWED AT THIS POINT I DON'T
THINK THIS COMPOUNDS THE PROBLEM
IF ANYTHING I IT YOU KNOW FOR
WHAT YOU SEE IT AS.
I THINK IT ACTUALLY.
WOULD RESULT IN IN LES MIS A
MISS COUNTS OR LESS
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AT THAT
POINT A OF OF PROCESSING BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE AS MANY FORMS
FLYING AROUND BECAUSE. AT THIS
POINT THIRD SORT TWO SETS OF
PAPER COMING IN AT ALL SO WHEN
THEY HAD TO GO THROUGH AND
RECOUNT YEARS THERE AND THEY
WERE TRYING TO MATCH THAT. TO
THE REGISTRATION FILE RIGHT IN
HERE.
MISTAKEN IN ONE PLACE SO IF
ANYTHING.
THAT NINE PERCENT OR WHATEVER
MAY HAVE BEEN.
IN IN PURE WOULD BE EASIER TO
GET TO I GUESS IS HOW I SEE THIS
NAM SO MY UNDERSTANDING THAT IS
THIS WOULD BE IN LIEU UP SO
INSTEAD OF PEOPLE SHOWING UP AND
DOING SAME DAY REGISTRATION.
THEY WOULD FILL OUT A
PROVISIONAL THE PROVISIONAL
WOULD ACT OUT YOUR SAME DAY
REGISTRATION SO THE SAME DAY
REGISTRATION GOES AWAY
PROVISIONAL TAKES ITS PLACE.
PROVISIONAL TAKES
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT IS
TO CUT BACK ON THE AMOUNT OF
PAPERWORK THIS ACTUALLY DOES THE
OPPOSITE IF IF YOU ARE
ELIMINATING SAME DAY
REGISTRATION AND REPLACING A
PROVISIONAL THAT AXIS SAME DAY
REGISTRATION. THAT DOES
ELIMINATE ONE ELEMENT BUT IF
YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUOUS SAME DAY
REGISTRATION AND THEN ALSO HAVE
THEM VOTE PROVISIONAL BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE REQUIRED IF
YOU'RE DOING A SAME DAY
REGISTRATION YOU WOULD THEN HAVE
TO CAST A PROVISIONAL BALLOTS IN
TIME. YOU WOULD HAVE DUPLICATION
AT THAT POINT NOW WHAT HAPPENS
THEN IF YOU'RE AUTOMATICALLY
VOTING VB ADAM YOU FORGOT YOUR
VB I'M YOU DON'T RECEIVE YOUR
BBM WAS DELAYED WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE. YOU FILL OUT A
PROVISIONAL NOW ARE YOU
DUPLICATING THE EFFORTS AT THE
RV BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO
THINK THAT THIS HAS TO BE SAME
DAY REGISTRATION HOW ARE THEY
GONNA MERGING PERCH. TO MAKE
SURE YOU DON'T HAVE YOUR
REGISTRATION TWO OR THREE TIMES.
YOUR MIND BY BY AT LEAST THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO
IT SO SO.
.
ONE TO MAKE SURE THAT I. I FULLY
UNDERSTAND WORD WHERE YOUR
QUESTION IS COMING FROM BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING. SIDE THIS
OUR PROCESS OF SAME DAY
REGISTRATION.
I IS NOT NECESSARILY THEN MOVING
TO A PROVISIONAL PROCESS
THAT PROVISIONAL VOTING AS YOU
MENTIONED HAPPENS FOR ADMITTED
FOR REASONS BUT PRIMARILY FOR
THOSE PEOPLE THAT FORGET THE
VOTE BY MAIL OR. WHO JUST FOR
THE CONVENIENCE OF GOING TO A
DIFFERENT POLLING PLACE ARE NOT
ON THE ROSTER AND I WANT TO VOTE
THEIR?
SAVE A REGISTRATIONS A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT ANIMAL
BECAUSE THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT I
HAVE DECIDED NOT TO REGISTER
BEFORE THAT FIFTEEN DAY CLOSE OF
REGISTRATION AND DECIDED. I OR
FOR FOR WHATEVER REASON THAT GUY
NOW II AFTER THE CLOSE OF
REGISTRATION THEY WANT TO COME
TO OUR OFFICE AND BE ABLE TO
REGISTER. AND VOTE AT THE SAME
TIME
SO THAT AND THE WORLD IS THAT IF
WE'RE MERGING THESE TWO
DOCUMENTS OF AN AFFIDAVIT OF
REGISTRATION AND AN ENVELOPE.
I'VE THAT IS THE PROCESS THEY
COME IN THEY COMPLETE THE
ENVELOPE.
OR THAT AFFIDAVIT REGISTRATION
WHICH IS THE ENVELOPE WHICH ALSO
REQUIRES THEM TO. PROVIDE SOME
PROVISIONAL AIR.
VOTING INFORMATION AND THEN
THEY OTE IT'S NOT AS IF THEY GO
THROUGH STEP ONE AND THEN THEY
GO TO A SECOND STEP FROM MORE
PAPERWORK BIG CURRENTLY M. THE
WAY IT STANDS NOW IF YOU DO SAME
DEAD REGISTRATION YOU STILL THEN
HAVE TO VOTE BY PROVISIONAL
BALLOT. YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO PUT
IN IN TRADITIONAL VOTING STREAM
THAT IT IS SO THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD THERE'S ALREADY A
DOUBLE STEP PROCESS THAT'S PUT
INTO PLACE WHERE WERE ALREADY
BEGINNING TO LEARN. WHAT SAME
DAY REGISTRATION MEANS BECAUSE
THIS IS OUR FIRST ELECTION CYCLE
THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH IT SO
NOW ADDING ANOTHER ANOTHER
HURDLE? ON BECAUSE I'LL TELL YOU
MY REGISTRAR VOTER INSANE MEDINA
COUNTY THE LARGEST
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND MASS IN THE
UNITED STATES THE WAY WE HAVE
PROCESSED IT IS WHEN YOU TURN IN
A PROVISIONAL BALLOT THEY'RE
GONNA SEND YOUR VOTER
REGISTRATION IN THE MAIL.
THEY'RE GOING TO MISS JUST THE
PROCESS BECAUSE WE WANT TO COUNT
EVERY SINGLE LEGAL FELT THAT
THERE IS TO IT TO COUNT. BUT IN
THIS SCENARIO THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING IS WE WOULD STILL HAVE
THAT LONG FORM THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HARPER SHOWED BUT THEN
YOU WOULD ALSO HAVE THE VERY
LARGE ENVELOPE. AND THEN YOU
WOULD THEN LEAVE IT TO THE
REGISTRAR TO TRY AND OVERLAP
THOSE TO YOU AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE DUPLICATION
BECAUSE TO YOUR POINT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME
DETERMINING WHICH ONES COME IN
WITH SAME DAY REGISTRATION AND
PBM. ISSUE ME AND PROVISIONAL AS
IF THEY ALREADY ARE REGISTERED
VPM OR THE REGISTER TRADITIONAL
POLL VOTING BUT THEY JUST AND
SHOW UP TO THE PRECINCT.
THINK I MIGHT STILL BE MISSING
YOUR PET YOUR LARGER POINT I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT JOHN.
I I WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT WHAT
THE EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO BE
FOR VOTER AYE IS NOT GOING TO BE
EXACTLY WHAT MAYBE YOUR YOUR
THINKING THAT IT IS NOW.
AB A PERSON WOULD COME AND THEY
WOULD.
COMPLETE THIS GUY AFFIDAVIT OF
REGISTRATION WHICH IS ALSO PART
OF THE ABOUT PROVISIONAL AND
BELOW.
FOR A CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION EXPERIENCE
AYE THEY WOULDN'T BE SENT A
VOTER REGISTRATION CARD
AFTERWARDS SO THERE'S AND I KNOW.
AND AND I'VE JUST.
AND A NOTABLY HERE IMPOSTER
COUNTY WE DON'T DO THAT BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE VOTER COMPLETED
VOTER REGISTRATION CARD WHEN
THEY'RE THERE.
IF THEY NEED TO FOR IT IF THEY
COME IN FOR PROVISIONAL.
VOTING EXPERIENCE.
MOST THE TIME IF WE CAN SEE THAT
THE PERSON WAS ISSUED ABOUT
REGISTRY EXUDING A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT AND JUST NEED A
REPLACEMENT VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT.
THEY DON'T NEED DIFFERENT IF A
LOT OF VOTER REGISTRATION CARD
SO THAT I THINK THAT THE
STREAMLINING OF THE PROCESS.
YOU'RE YOU'RE ENVISIONING A
PROCESS THAT REQUIRES MORE
PAPERWORK AND I THINK THAT GUY.
YOU'RE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
IS A A PROCESS THAT REQUIRES
LESS PAPERWORK BUT SEAT REALLY.
BUT I APPRECIATE ON INTO MY
CONCERN IS AND I THINK WE ARE
KIND OF TALKING AROUND EACH
OTHER IS OKAY SO IF THE
TRADITIONAL AND BALK OF
PROVINCIAL BALLOTS ARE THE TWO
CATEGORIES WE BOTH AGREED ON.
AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE NOT TURNED
IN THEIR VIVIANE AND PEOPLE THAT
HAVE I CHOSEN TO GO TO A
DIFFERENT PRECINCT.
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD WE NEED
PROVISIONAL BALLOT AND THEN TAKE
THE DOUBLE DUTY OF BEING A VOTER
REGISTRATION WOULD HAVE F.
PERFECTLY GOOD VOTER
REGISTRATION FORM?
A. WELL BECAUSE I BUT SAY. LET'S
ENVISIONED THIS PROCESS WHERE
I'D THE PERSON AT I NEEDS TO
COME IN AND COMPLETE A
PROVISIONAL AND PHILIP.
YEAH I AND YET THEY FALL IN THAT
SITUATION WHERE I THEY ARE
PERFECTLY WERE REGISTERED AND
THERE'S NO NEED FOR THEM TO
UPDATE REGISTRATION.
I THEN.
THE ENVELOPE YEAH I THAT
REQUIRES THE AFFIDAVIT OF
REGISTRATION INFORMATION TO BE
COMPLETED. DOESN'T NEED TO BE
COMPLETED THAT INSTANCE RIGHT SO
YOU HAVE A FORM THAT HAS ALL THE
INFORMATION ON IT BUT THERE ARE
PARTS THAT YOU MAY NOT NEED TO
COMPLETE TO BE ABLE TO.
VERIFY THAT THAT BALLOT IS
GOING TO BE
CAST CORRECTLY
SO I IN THAT SENSE I. THE PARTS
OF THE ENVELOPE THAT NEED TO BE
COMPLETED FOR A PERSON THAT JUST
NEEDS A VOTE BY MAIL BECAUSE
THEY NEVER RECEIVED IT OR THEY
LOST IT OR THEY'VE. MISSED
MARK DEBT AND THE NEED OF A
SECOND.
I CAN BE COMPLETED AND THOSE
PEOPLE THAT NEED THE ACT OF THE.
FORM FOR AN AFFIDAVIT OF
REGISTRATION
CAN COMPLETE THE ENTIRE PART OF
THE AND.
OKAY SO I'M WITH ME IN MY OWN
TIME AM MIGHT MY ONLY COMMENT IS
I I RESPECT AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO MY
CONCERN IS IS WHEN WE ACTUALLY
GO TO THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT A TRADITIONAL
R. O. V. ANY GIVEN TME HAS
MAYBE THIRTY TO FORTY EMPLOYEES
DURING THE YEAR AND THE MONEY
COMES ELECTION TIME THEY HAVE
MAYBE SIX HUNDRED SEVEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES. AND ALLOW THOSE
EMPLOYEES HAVE FORTY FIVE
MINUTES TO AN HOUR AND A HALF
WORTH OF TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THIS DETERMINATION WHEN
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH AND
PROCESSING PROVISIONAL BALLOTS
IF YOU'VE EVER GONE THROUGH THAT
I'M SURE YOU HAVE. THAT YOU'VE
EVER SAT THERE I STOOD THERE FOR
TWENTY ONE DAYS AND WATCHED AS
THEY GO THROUGH WHEN THEY JUST
BASICALLY HAVE OF SOMEONE
TRAINED WITH FORTY FIVE MINUTES
WORTH OF EXPERIENCE MAKING
TERMINATION COUNT DON'T COUNT.
COUNT DON'T COUNT GOES THROUGH
FOUR DIFFERENT TIMES DEPENDING
ON BUT THE PROCESS IS THAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL ROV. BUT THAT'S MY
POINT YOU HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT PROCESSES AND TO TAKE
A PROVISIONAL BALLOT THAT ARE
READY IT'S EXTREMELY CHALLENGING
FOR AN RV TO PROCESS ACCURATELY
AND THEN ADDED THAT EXTRA
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER THEY
ARE READY A REGISTERED OR SHOULD
BE REGISTERED. I THINK YOU'RE
PUTTING A LITTLE MORE BURDEN
THAN KEEPING IT STREAMLINED ON A
TRADITIONAL REGISTRATION FORM
WHERE THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR
SINGLE SOURCE RESPONSIBILITY IS
ON THAT PARTICULAR FORM. I
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
A POTENTIAL AREA OF.
MISUNDERSTANDING A MISTAKE NOT
INTENTIONALLY BUT CERTAINLY.
BASED ON THE LEVEL EXPERIENCE
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WILL BE
PROCESSING THESE BALLOTS.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE WHAT YOU'RE
ATTEMPTING TO ACHIEVE HERE AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE
COMPLICATING THE SYSTEM EVEN
MORE THAN IT HAS.
THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK AND
THE COLLOQUY IT'S ACTUALLY.
SOME HASN'T BEEN REYES
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS SO.
I DO APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
CENTER SO WE GOT TO CLOSE.
SURE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT DEPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
I I DO THINK THAT THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL STREAMLINE THE
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS FOR VOTERS. AS WELL AS
FOR ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IF THERE
ARE COMPLICATIONS I'M ASSUMING
Y. HERE BACK.
FROM OUR FROM OUR CLERKS AND
AND REGISTRARS.
ABOUT THAT AND CAN.
MAKE IT A SMALL CHANGES AS
NECESSARY ARE BUT I DO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE A CALL
VOTE. THE MOST MISTER PASS ROMAN
AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER. HARPER NO
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE MARK
STONE. MARK STONE AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NO WEBER.
WEBER AYE. THAT BILLS OUT ON A
FIVE TO TWO VOTES AND MR STERN.
THAT HE'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY THREE SHORT
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
.
A BIPARTISAN MOTION AND THE
SECOND SENATOR STEINBERG SP
TWELVE EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
FOURTEEN ENABLES THE STATE TO DO
THESE THINGS TO REMOVE THINGS
OFF THE BALLOT IF NEED BE LOCAL
SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY.
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
GRAVEL THANK YOU XANDER PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TERRY
BRENNAN BEHALF FAST HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA PREPARED FORTY FIVE
MINUTE SOBRE MARKETS AND UNTIL.
WHICH I WILL DISTRIBUTE IT
ANOTHER TIME.
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNER TYPE OF
THANK YOU TERRY. ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT COULD MY
CURIOSITY UPTHE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
DOOR ROSE THE GOVERNMENT VOTERS
TO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
BILL THANK YOU.
JACK WHAT ARE COMMON CAUSE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SINGING NUN THEY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT A
COLLEGE OR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE ARE MOTION A SECOND NO
QUESTIONS NO COMMENTS. CENTER
STARTED TO CLOSE BECKLEY ESCRIBO
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE GO VOTE
EMOTION A STEEP PATH TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE HARPER AYE HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE MARK STONE. MARK
STONE AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THAT IS OUT ON A SEVEN TWO ZERO
VOTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UNDER STERN
AND SO WE WILL LIFT THE CALL.
IS IT IS IT GONE CALLERS OPENING
IT UP IT'S NOT ON CALL DOES THAT
ARE TO GO DOWN. SO WE'RE JUST
LET.
ABSENT MEMBERS AND ON.
TO ITEM ONE.
I'M ITS S. B. TEN EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH WITH THAT WERE
ADJOURNED